what if Jing raised gone from the start
this fictional Hunter content is brought
to you by misplay but more about them
later so Jing gets memd on a lot by
Hunter Hunter Fans I am one of them
however it needs to be noted that Jing
did not originally intend to abandon
gone originally he just wanted to leave
gone on whale island with his
grandmother for a while Jing's
grandmother that is and gon's great
grandmother assumedly this was because
he was going to go somewhere
particularly dangerous to conduct a
sorted Hunter business but then Meo
stepped in and yelled at Jing aot
because thought that Jing wasn't a fit
parent and took full custody of gone
which I think implies legal custody as
well but in general Jing had no problem
with the idea of raising gone I mean not
full-time of course but you sporadically
and in fact unless gone was the result
of a how shall we say particularly Roar
encounter then that was probably the
plan all along to have a child and then
to raise it and yes there is an argument
to be made that Meo taken gone was also
part of a calculated plan by Jing to not
raise his own child after creating it
for reasons and it's not implausible
because he's been able to predict a lot
of crazy stuff but for the purposes of
this video we are going to ask the
question of what would have happened if
Jing raised gone and the first thing we
need to address is the lack of influence
of Meo because in this scenario her
absence is every bit as important as
Jing's presence and in the sole care of
Jing I think that gone would risk losing
some inate kindness as well as an
appreciation for the simple things in
life for example one of my favorite sets
of pages in Hunter Hunter comes from
chapter 345 where we see gone return to
wh Island and there's this montage of
him happily spending the day doing
mundane chores with Meo without her
influence gone probably ends up
significantly more on the Jing end of
the spectrum so consumed by adventure
and accomplishments that he never really
has time to step back and appreciate
anything gone would also be potentially
Less airheaded in general if only due to
Jing's mental training I mean gone in no
world is ever going to be a natural
intellectual but he'll definitely be a
step above what we see in the series but
then we also have the issue of drive so
much of who gone is is comprised of his
desire to meet his father a desire which
Jing used to train Gone From a Distance
giving him a trail of Trials to
ultimately find him so what would gon's
drive be if he was with Jing the whole
time I don't know if there would even be
one and he may actually end up becoming
a lot like kilwa a child raised with a
twisted but loving family and struggling
with the idea of what he wants to be
like what he confided and gone you're
cool for having all these goals I don't
have a plan I don't know what I want to
do with my life there's a list of things
that I don't want to do like taking over
the family business so that's Kila but
gon's case is different because at heart
he's a natural Hunter and we saw this
when he did finally find Jing and he
told Meo I don't know how to put it I
guess it wasn't that I wanted to see him
I realized after I saw him that my goal
had been to find him so it was never
about Jing himself it was about the hunt
so here's my proposal What If instead of
hunting for his father gone decided to
hunt for his mother the only reason why
he shows no interest in his biological
mother in series is because he considers
Meo his mother and therefore the case
closed so a very clever Jing thing to do
could be to train his son in a similar
way as he did to find him but organizing
all of the clues to lead to gon's mother
instead so gon's early life is probably
shaped much like kils just less sadistic
more training less torture Jing probably
isn't going to do stuff like whipping
and poisoning or electric and gone but I
don't know if it's going to be much
better either it's not going to be an
easy childhood because Jing is going to
understand the importance of building
his son's physical abilities that's the
foundation and once gone has a solid
foundation I feel like Jing would go
down the silver zelic route of Dr
dropping his son off at Heaven's Arena
and telling him not to come back until
he's reached the 200th floor so for some
reference kilaa was sent to Heaven's
Arena when he was 6 years old and whilst
it only took him 2 months to conquer the
first 150 floors it took him a total of
2 years to reach the 200th floor so
under these conditions even if gone
doesn't arrive at the same time that
kilaa does that gives the boys a huge
crossover period where they could meet
and begin their friendship as the only 6
to 8-year-olds competing at Heaven's
Arena however even after being trained
by Jing director I do still think that
gone will be lagging behind
comparatively to the uh traditional zic
family Training Method either way what
I'm seeing is an epic child vild
Showdown on the 199th floor because
after years of fighting gone and kilwa
then meeting combat to decide who will
reach the 200th for first to complete
their task but as alluded to I reckon
that kiloa would probably be winning
this fight so gone and Kila po ways with
gone eventually reaching the 200th floor
himself and thus finally being allowed
to return to Jing so the reason why both
Jing and Silva would stipulate only
reaching the 200th FL is because that
point on is when nen becomes relevant
and neither father would want their
child initiated by the various n do
Wells of Heaven's Arena and you might
think that it would have been a good
idea for Jing to teach gone Ora control
from a very early age but that's not
necessarily true initially it's more
important for a person to fully push the
boundaries of basic Humanity before
unlocking what takes them Beyond and to
take you beyond is today's sponsor
mistplay a loyalty app for those of us
who play mobile games games of all
different genres which can earn you
points towards redeeming gift cards from
Brands like Amazon Walmart Visa Xbox and
Playstation with over 60 million doll
uing gift cards already having been
redeemed mplay is a fantastic way to add
value to your already valuable gaming
time whether that's by playing the
delightsome Royal match the surprisingly
sheap based soliter or ever ever so many
more I could sit here just listing them
on and on into Infinity but even that
would be taking away your valuable
gaming time and therefore the reward
time that you could be earning you can
and should check out misplay through my
link in the description which gives you
200 bonus points for signing up today
and you can use code New World 50 to get
an additional 50 points and thank you so
so much to misplay because it's sponsors
like this that give us the ability to
keep producing consistent hunt hunt
content so give them a big thanks from
us but for now it's back to you me a few
short years later Jing wood prompt gone
to take the hunter exam gone originally
did this as his first clue to find Jing
by following in his footsteps but Jing
will come up with some sort of clever
way to convince gone to take it by using
his mother and we can be pretty sure
that it would be the 287th exam just
like in the series because Jing took the
hunter exam when he was 11 years old and
thus he will see that as the path going
forward for gone as well unless he sees
gon as having even more potential than
him in which case he might even get the
gone to take the exam at 10 years old
funnily enough Either Way Gone will run
into Hoka because he took both exams as
well having been disqualified for almost
killing an examina in the 286 exam so
there's no avoiding peing he soak his he
soak his interest in any case we're
going to go with the 287th exam and
something very very important about this
is that gon is unlikely to meet kopa or
aoria prior to the first official phase
or indeed at all gon met them because
they were on the same ship which was
passing through whale Island but if he's
with Jing then gone could be anywhere in
the world at this point which is really
bad news for both kopa and Leorio
because they very potentially fail the
qualification exam as the boat captain
was less than impressed with their
reasons to be become hunters and even
took their starting a fight as a sign of
withdrawing from the exam and if gone
hadn't been there I think the captain
would have failed both of them and we
don't see either of them this year
luckily enough with his alternate
upbringing gon shouldn't need the power
of friendship to find his way to the
exam site in fact gon enters the 287th
exam almost absurdly well equipped and
shouldn't really experience any hardship
whatsoever other than the presence of
Hoka and damy this exam is a joke to him
much like it was to kilwa who speaking
of gone will reunite with and they'll
form their his Duo so without Leorio and
kopa there's no real way of telling how
many people will make it through to the
final but I can guarantee you that in
this day God and Kila would definitely
be two of them but the outcome will be
more or less the same with kilwa being
booted by ilam and causing a bit of a
bit of a death scene thus disqualifying
himself but qualifying gone and in good
news for gone he might not end up
getting demolished by Hanzo if he ends
up facing him in round one again Hanzo
wasn't a n user so this would end up
being trained martial artist versus
other trained smaller child martial
artist now with his shining new license
I imagine that gone would go after to
kiloa all by himself because he's a big
boy now he's licensed and everything and
gone probably doesn't even need to train
to open the testing Gates either because
we are way beyond that and luckily
there's well there's no trouble here at
all because the zic family AR
essentially boils down Kila was saying
I'm leaving and then Silva going yeah
right and from here gon and kilaa have
options in the series they go to
Heaven's Arena so that gone can train to
give back hisoka's batch and assuming
that gon still lost to hoker in the
hunter exam which he did gon is going to
want to do that at some point but in
this world they have another option
which is for gone to bring Kila back to
visit his father Jing the strongest
person that gone knows and therefore
probably the best to train and I say
home but what I mean is wherever Jing
happens to be floating at the time and
now that gone is ready for all of for
all of the nen this is when Jing decides
to start Aura training and kilwa can tag
along as well because why not that's
what he does even though he didn't pass
the hunter exam in the series Wing
taught him anyway so why not Jing and
under Jing's tutelage gone and kilwa are
probably going to progress at an even
even greater rate than they did
originally not just because they have
one of the world's greatest nen Masters
teaching them but because gone is both
physically and mentally more prepared
for this and the equation of gone and
kilawa always works as a multiplier
however much better gone is only adds
more to kilawa and however better Kila
is only adds that much more to gone Jing
may even send them back into Heaven's
Arena to compete at higher levels
however gone might not run into hisoka
timing is very important here because
Hoka has somewhere to be in a couple of
months so it very much depends on Jing's
view of their progress and who knows he
might even have a different method of
training them for n combat but once Jing
de's gone ready he's going to give him
the memory card for Greed Island the
game that Jin specifically built to
train gone and that leads us into York
New City and this Arc is going to be
extremely different and practically
non-existent because for one neither
Leorio nor karapa are here karapa needs
to pass the exam to begin hunting The
Troop and who knows what Leorio is doing
but it's not anything Hunter related but
that means that the Phantom troop have a
very easy time even with hisoka's horny
hindrances and notably for them neither
pakunoda nor uin dies G and Killa
probably don't even run into the Phantom
troop there's no reason for them to and
I guess the really great thing about
York new city is that nothing really
needs to happen for gone and kilaa to
get where they're going because in the
end they will fail to acquire a copy of
Greed Island and join betara Squad as
the highly gifted NLS they are and once
they get to Greed Island gone and kilwa
do not have a choice they will be
further trained by bisy because she was
very forceful when making them her
students and at one point during this
training K will leave to take the next
Hunter exam which is hilarious because
both kopa and Loria will be at this exam
as well both of whom will get knocked
out and Kil was candidate Sorter and
fail the exam again this year and
probably have to take the 289th hunter
exam which could also be a problem
because this was the first exam under
cheo's tenure as chairman of the
association and it was designed
specifically to find candidates to issue
provisional licenses to for the Dark
Continent Voyage in all seriousness kopa
and Leorio may fail this exam as well
because neither of them are equipped to
be so much as saying the words dark
consonant and so they'll probably have
to go and take the 290th exam if we even
have one because that's further into the
future than Hunter Hunter has ever gone
stepping back to Greed Island in the
quest to collect all of the fun cards we
will need to play dodgeball but Hoka
won't be on the island to help us and
this is because he was playing the game
to find a nen excist for CR but KOLO
hasn't been cursed by kopa so Greed
Island is entirely Phantom troop free
that's a problem not so much to fill out
the team we could find another random to
do that but because it was really the
teamwork of gone kilawa and very
importantly Hoka that ultimately won the
match so now gon would have to beat
Razer in a pure Ora slugfest and in his
favor gone is significantly better
equipped for it but also he might just
die that's a possibility but we'll give
gone the benefit of Jing's training say
they overcome Raza defeat genr and
complete Greed Island at which point
gone will activate a company expecting
to be pled right before his mother now
this could also go one of two ways in
the manga Jing said that he wouldn't
want to see gone if he brought any
friends and look gun's bringing a friend
but that was to meet him Jing the the
cool hunter man and he likely wouldn't
employ the same standards to meet his
mother so I think this might be where
gon's first big hunt ends we see the
mystery woman gone says sup Mama sup
mama why the am I saying that there
is of course the minor issue of chimera
ants happening elsewhere in the world
but that's the strange beauty of Hunter
Hunter you could take the main character
out of the story and most events will
still have the same outcome Isaac netro
is going to successfully activate the
poor man's Rose against the King which
will poison both he and the royal guard
fing after him probably with much
heavier losses on the extermination team
although kite might not die and I dare
say from here gone as a fully-fledged
hunter will need to find a new goal that
might be to go to the Dark Continent
with Jing as gon said he wanted to do if
he still had nen but it could also be
countless other things as well kilwa
might even tag along because their
relationship hasn't been damaged yet
which means that alaka stays trapped but
goo stays alive and kopa isn't abort the
black whale 1 which will no doubt affect
the entire outcome of the succession war
and potentially fate of the world and
that's what would happen if Jing raised
gone